merci Fabien jeune aime nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure on est
ravi de vous recevoir pour la première
fois dans cette émission vous êtes élu
de Saône-et-Loire rattachée au groupe
les républicains et vous êtes l'un des
rapporteurs du projet de loi sur
l'industrie verte qui est examiné en ce
moment au Sénat on va bien sûr
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord un mot de l'actualité et
d'abord ces images qui ont choqué à
Bordeaux l'agression de cette grand-mère
et de cette petite fille devant leur
domicile l'agresseur présumée qui avait
été condamnée à 15 reprises pour des
faits d'infraction routière d'infraction
à la législation sur les stupéfiants il
est également suivi sur le plan
psychiatrique qu'est-ce qu'il y a eu une
défaillance dans la réponse pénale
comment déjà ne pas être pris au tripes
par ces par ces images parce que toute
image d'agression est bien sûr très
perturbante mais lorsqu'en plus cela
touche que nous avons de plus cher c'est
à dire les enfants et leurs
grands-parents nous sommes effectivement
saisis je crois qu'effectivement cela
illustre une nouvelle fois la
problématique de la récidive vous savez
40% des gens qui sont condamnés en
France le sont en état de récidive et
30% des gens qui une sorte de prison
vont récidiver dans dans les 12 mois
donc il y a un vrai sujet une politique
pénale à modifier en ce sens et comme
vous le disiez également je crois que
cela illustre les difficultés que nous
ressentons dans l'ensemble des
départements sur la psychiatrie nous
avons un sujet sur la psychiatrie les
gens ont beaucoup de mal à pouvoir
recevoir les soins dont ils ont besoin
il est vrai que depuis 1970 on a perdu
60% des lits d'hospitalisation en
psychiatrie je crois qu'on en voit
aujourd'hui le résultat et qu'il faut
vraiment une réponse très rapide sur ce
sujet l'autre actualité aujourd'hui
c'est Gérald Darmanin qui présente en
conseil des ministres le décret
dissolution des soulèvements de la Terre
ce collectif écologiste dont la
dissolution est envisagée depuis les
événements de sainte-souligne il y a eu
aussi ce qui s'est passé ce week-end du
côté des manifestations contre le projet
Lyon-Turin c'est une dissolution
justifiée pour vous
je crois que notre pays garantit un
espace d'expression de liberté de
sensibilité aux problématiques
environnementales et écologique la
limite c'est la violence on ne peut pas
accepter effectivement que se développe
toujours plus de violence dans notre
dans notre pays
est-ce que le soulèvement c'est la
meilleure façon de garantir une solution
je ne le crois pas je crois qu'il y a
d'autres
je crois qu'effectivement il faut
envoyer un signal fort pour marquer le
fait que nous pouvons débattre de tout
en France mais sans aller jusqu'à la
violence d'actualité du Sénat on est
sénateurs qui ont donc entamé depuis
hier après-midi l'examen du projet de
loi sur l'industrie verte qui vise à
concilier réindustrialisation du pays et
transition écologique vous êtes l'un des
rapporteurs de ce texte on en parle tout
de suite avec notre journaliste
parlementaire ça vient de chez
[Musique]
Jean Samia bonjour Oriane bonjour Fabien
Genet et Samia vous avez suivi
attentivement hier le début de l'examen
du projet de loi sur un industriel verte
oui c'est un projet de loi imaginé par
le gouvernement pour réindustrialiser la
France et décarboner notre économie d'où
l'idée de développer une industrie verte
comment et bien principalement en
facilitant l'installation de nouveaux
sites industriels grâce d'abord à une
réduction des délais d'autorisation
d'ouverture d'une usine le gouvernement
veut les faire passer de 17 à 9 mois il
veut aussi créer un crédit d'impôt
industriel verte pour développer les
panneaux solaires les batteries les
pompes à chaleur etc et puis l'autre
nouveauté pour financer l'industrie
verte c'est la création d'un plan
d'épargne vert que des parents pourront
ouvrir pour leurs enfants et qui sera
mieux rémunéré que le livret A et puis
il y a désormais dans ce texte Samuel
les mesures proposées par le Sénat oui
la première modification a été votée
hier sur votre proposition Fabien Genet
c'est la multiplication par 5 de
l'amande pour les entreprises qui ne
publient pas leur bilan carbone
normalement toutes les entreprises de
plus de 500 salariés doivent le faire
mais seul 65% d'entre elles publient le
bilan de leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre les fautifs risquent
aujourd'hui 10000 euros d'amende vous
avez augmenté ce plafond à 50.000 euros
contre les vies du gouvernement regarder
la réaction du ministre de l'Industrie
50 000 euros ça nous semble quand même
très élevés sans doute trop élevés nous
n'avons pas de d'objections de principe
à une hausse de l'amende on aurait pu
envisager 15000 ou 20000 euros mais
50000 euros ça nous semble beaucoup à ce
stade nous proposons donc de supprimer
le quintuplement de l'amende mais sommes
ouverts évidemment
une solution peut-être moins ambitieuse
mais tout aussi efficace
par 5 de l'amande pour les entreprises
qui ne publient pas leur bilan carbone
et vous l'avez fait donc on vient de le
voir contre la vie du gouvernement mais
il faudra que ça passe ensuite à
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que ça a
une chance de passer nous l'espérons
nous l'espérons un contrairement à ce
que dit le ministre je ne pense pas que
ce soit disproportionné il faut savoir
que plus de la moitié des entreprises
qui sont soumises à cette obligation ne
la respecte pas et pour nous si on veut
décarboner l'industrie il faut
absolument à la fois y voir plus clair
donc il faut que nous disposions de
chiffres il faut également que les
entreprises puissent y voir plus clair
et puis c'est un élément également de
sensibilisation donc je ne doute pas que
nos collègues de l'Assemblée seront
sensibles à ces arguments
Samia il y a aussi une grande inquiétude
dans des sénateurs dans ce texte c'est
la question de l'artificialisation des
sols oui parce que pour construire des
usines et bien il faut des terrains or
le foncier disponible il est de plus en
plus rare et les élus locaux sont
désormais contraints par un objectif 0
artificialisation net des sols qu'on
appelle aussi pour les connaisseurs le
zan et donc dans ce texte les sénateurs
ont précisé que les futurs sites
industriels ne devront pas être comptés
dans le calcul de cet objectif 0
artificialisation net des sols pour ne
pas être encore plus contraint alors
est-ce que le gouvernement va les suivre
les sénateurs ont l'air d'en douter
fortement regardez la Commission a aussi
introduit une mesure phare que vous
soutenez je crois monsieur le ministre
sans que l'on en trouve la moindre trace
dans votre projet de loi l'exclusion du
zan vous en avez parlé c'est bien de le
dire nous venons de l'entendre ce sera
mieux de le faire est-ce que vous aussi
Fabien Genet vous vous doutez que le
gouvernement soutiennent cette mesure on
sait que le ministre de l'écologie
Christophe Béchu lui il y est
nous sommes effectivement inquiets nous
sommes effectivement inquiets parce que
sur Lausanne le Sénat a pris ses
responsabilités et a voulu desserrer un
peu les taux qui est celui de la loi
climat résilience nous respectons
l'objectif de plus de sobriété foncière
mais effectivement nous voulons que cela
s'applique de façon pragmatique et
réaliste et nous avons entendu lors du
débat sur la proposition de loi sur
Lausanne Christophe Béchu le ministre de
l'écologie effectivement avoir des
propos très différents de ceux que le
ministre le maire a tenu a tenu hier
dans l'hémicycle alors je sais
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes le jour de la
fête de la musique donc peut-être qu'il
y a là un duo un duo ministériel en tous
les cas cela nous inquiète d'autant plus
que la proposition de loi du Sénat est
cette semaine à l'Assemblée nationale et
que les premières décisions rendues par
la commission des affaires économiques
ne va pas forcément dans le sens dans le
sens de ce que nous avons fait au Sénat
donc nous serons très très vigilants sur
ce point il ne faut pas que le zan
devienne un 0 aménagement nouveau parce
que et bien ce serait ce serait le pays
qui en pâtirait il y a des divergences
pardon Samia après on va continuer sur
le texte mais sur le Zen il y a des
divergences notamment sur la question de
la garantie rurale qui avait mis en
place le Sénat pour aider les communes
rurales dans la mise en place de sésame
pour leur laisser quelques marches de
manœuvre encore à l'Assemblée ça semble
plus compliqué mais Elisabeth Borg qui
était dans la Vienne la semaine dernière
elle s'est dit favorable à une garantie
rurale sans toutefois préciser les
modalités vous êtes optimiste du coup
sur un compromis là-dessus je laisse
faire j'espère ce compromis ardemment
parce qu'il est attendu sur le terrain
c'est toutes les semaines je vais à la
rencontre des mers des communes de mon
département et pas un maire ne me parle
pas de cette inquiétude est-ce que
demain on va pouvoir encore aménager nos
communes et vous savez c'est un
processus descendant avec la l'État qui
se positionne puis la région et puis
ensuite et bien les maires
bénéficient des quelques miettes qu'on
va bien vouloir pouvoir laisser et donc
au Sénat nous nous étions absolument
déterminés à garantir à chaque commune
la possibilité d'avoir un développement
minimal c'est cette garantie rurale
du résultat oui parce que d'une manière
générale en fait les sénateurs jugent
qui ce texte il est flou qu'il n'est pas
à la hauteur des enjeux il juge même
qu'on arrivera pas à les atteindre avec
ce texte là qui ne serait qu'une
agrégation mesure technique pourquoi
pourquoi ce point de vue des sénateurs
qu'est-ce qui lui manque à ce texte
pourquoi ce point de vue parce que je
crois que nous partageons l'ambition qui
a été affichée au départ comme vous le
disiez de réindustrialisation et de
décarbonation de notre de notre pays
donc nous avions de très fortes attentes
comme nous les avons sur le sur le
terrain il y a effectivement beaucoup de
mesures techniques qui pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles vont dans le bon
sens et celle qui n'allait pas
complètement dans le bon sens nous les
avons redressés nous sommes en train de
les redresser avec mes collègues
sénateurs mais effectivement c'est plus
finalement une un texte ballet par
rapport à d'autres textes qui ont déjà
été qui ont déjà été adoptés et
effectivement l'une des problématiques
c'est quel moyen quels moyens le
gouvernement va mettre derrière toutes
ces dispositions techniques il nous dit
que il nous renvoie au projet de loi de
finances à l'automne pour juger de
ces crédits nous serons là également
très attentifs parce que il y a de
bonnes intentions mais encore
faudra-t-il des crédits pour les
concrétiser le gouvernement promet la
création 40 000 emplois grâce à cette
loi est-ce que vous y croyez justement
sans voir quels moyens vont être mis
derrière
sur le terrain nous avons
vécu les fermetures des usines j'ai
moi-même dans ma commune eu à gérer des
fermetures d'entreprises c'était
l'industrie céramique dans ma commune de
Digoin je me suis retrouvé dans un
gymnase avec 300 salariés d'une
entreprise céramique qui venait d'être
licenciée donc je mesure effectivement
le dégât qu'a connu la
désindustrialisation de notre pays et
donc nous devons reconquérir
effectivement ces emplois industriels
ces activités mais par exemple je parle
de cet exemple dans ma commune
l'entreprise a laissé une friche
industrielle il y a donc un potentiel
foncier tout à fait intéressant mais
avec les pollutions passées qui existent
sur ce site il faudra des centaines de
milliers d'euros pour dépolluer la
friche avant de pouvoir la réutiliser
c'est donc la preuve qu'il faut beaucoup
de crédit et donc nous aurons ce débat
au projet de loi de finance vous vous
êtes très sévère dans votre rapport vous
dites que ce texte ne contribue qu'à la
marge rien industrialiser le pays et sur
l'autre vous dites aucun dispositif de
ce texte ne répond véritablement
l'objectif de réduction des émissions de
l'industrie française c'est un peu un
texte pour rien
nous sommes moins sévères qu'exigeants
et nous sommes exigeants parce que nous
avons de haute ambitions à la fois sur
la réindustrialisation et sur la
décarbonation donc ce texte est utile il
est utile il va permettre d'accélérer un
certain nombre de procédures il va
permettre d'avancer sur l'économie
circulaire par exemple sur la sortie
implicite du statut de déchet donc il y
a des avancées mais effectivement
c'est des ambitions très très fortes qui
nécessitent la mobilisation de tout le
pays donc nous aurons certainement y
revenir
qui était à votre place hier et il avait
l'air d'avoir très envie de trouver un
compromis avec les sénateurs vous êtes
optimiste sur un compromis
vous savez trouver un compromis avec le
ministre dans l'hémicycle ce sont les
sénateurs qui votent donc en général
nous y parvenons la question ce sera
ensuite avec l'Assemblée nationale c'est
mieux que le gouvernement soutienne les
mesures pour que ça arrive mais ce sera
ensuite surtout une problématique avec
l'Assemblée nationale et
la problématique c'est également pour le
ministre de trouver une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale donc vous voterez
le texte dans votre version
naturellement et est-ce que ce texte est
aussi un moyen de lutter contre le
rassemblement national qui prospère on
le sait dans les zones ou les usines
ferment je l'ai vu également dans dans
ma commune effectivement ce désespoir
que dont je vous parlais que j'ai pu
mesurer effectivement il s'est traduit
au fil des années les courbes sont assez
parallèles entre la réduction des
activités industrielles des emplois et
la montée des extrêmes et donc
effectivement il faut absolument que
nous puissions gagner ce pari de la
réindustrialisation parce qu'il en va de
notre souverain eté économique et de
l'aménagement des territoires et ce
texte peut le permettre de gagner ce
pari c'est une des petites pierres à
l'édifice mais je pense que le chemin
est encore très long sur stream
merci Samia à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure merci on reviendra dans le club
il y a beaucoup de sujets à voir avec
vous dans le Pavin oui on parlerait de
deux sujets on va ça tout à l'heure dans
une demi-heure merci Samia on va
continuer l'actualité avec vous
l'actualité dans votre département
maintenant on va Chalon-sur-Saône
retrouver Emmanuel boulon bonjour
Emmanuel merci beaucoup d'être avec nos
chefs d'information au Journal de
Saône-et-Loire on va parler d'un sujet
qui préoccupe les éleveurs avec vous
c'est la prolifération des loups
oui bonjour oui le loup qui a fait son
retour en Europe en France et aussi en
Bourgogne du Sud en Saône-et-Loire qui
s'est installé durablement vous voulez
poser une question à un monsieur Genet
comment on fait cohabiter le loup avec
les éleveurs
dans ce département pour certains
d'élevage
bonjour Emmanuel
c'est effectivement un sujet de
préoccupation majeure pour l'ensemble
des élus du département nous étions
d'ailleurs réunis en préfecture lundi
sur sur le sujet les attaques ont été
multipliées par deux en l'espace de
quelques mois
et finalement cela ne doit pas nous
étonner puisque il y a eu un plan de
réintroduction du loup et de protection
du loup dans notre pays et effectivement
il descend des montagnes dans les
vallées et il est en train de coloniser
des départements comme comme la
Saône-et-Loire cela crée de vrais
difficultés et une très grande détresse
chez chez nos éleveurs puisque après
avoir attaqué les ovins il est en train
d'attaquer les bovins et donc pour l'élu
du Charolais que je suis c'est une vraie
préoccupation je crois qu'il faut
aujourd'hui modifier le plan national
loup qui était fait pour protéger une
espèce qui avait disparu et qui était
menacée aujourd'hui d'après les derniers
comptages le chiffre qui était souhaité
de 500 loups en France a été très
largement dépassé d'ailleurs il y a un
vrai problème sur le comptage des loups
parce que les tirs de défense et de
prélèvement qui sont autorisés par ce
plan sont calculés en fonction de la
population lupine et donc si on
sous-estime celle-ci en sous-estime les
autorisations de tir et donc ça aboutit
à ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui à une
explosion du nombre de loups on parle
d'une croissance de plus de 20% d'une
année sur l'autre du nombre de loups et
donc il ne faut pas s'étonner qu'il y
ait ensuite des attaques et les préfets
d'ailleurs ont saisi les ministres sur
cette problématique de est-ce complète
il est ficelle finalement concevable de
pouvoir faire cohabiter et l'élevage et
le loup et donc nous nous battons avec
l'ensemble de mes collègues
parlementaires et des élus locaux pour
que très rapidement nous puissions avoir
la fin d'année obtenir des avancées sur
la modification de ce de ce plan loup et
d'ailleurs la présence du ministre dans
de l'agriculture dans le département
vendredi sera une bonne occasion pour
nous de lui rappeler cette impérieuse
nécessité parce qu'aujourd'hui
finalement ce n'est plus vraiment loup
qui est menacé c'est l'élevage c'est
l'élevage made in Saône-et-Loire c'est à
dire un élevage extensif qui est
respectueux des paysages que nous
voulons faire classer d'ailleurs à
l'Unesco le Charolais mais effectivement
l'élevage est menacé et donc il faut que
nous réagissions on va parler d'un autre
sujet Emmanuel avec vous dans l'édition
du Charolais vous revenez sur les
violences intempéries qui avaient touché
la région il y a un an
oui il y a un an donc un orage de grêle
et des conséquences assez spectaculaires
je voulais demander au sénateur où en
est-on un an après ce que toutes les
victimes ont été indemnisées on a fait
un portage effectivement on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a encore des toits bâchés et que
notamment la mairie d'igonze Étienne
Maire Monsieur Genet a été fortement
impacté mais savoir un petit point de
situation est-ce que toutes les victimes
ont été indemnisées finalement
aujourd'hui un an après
oui le 21 juin dernier il y a un an le
ciel nous tombait sur la tête j'étais à
Digoin ce jour-là ça a été un orage
absolument catastrophique aujourd'hui il
reste encore beaucoup à faire parce que
effectivement comme vous le notiez
beaucoup de toi sont encore bâchés alors
c'est moins un problème d'assurance
d'ailleurs que de couvreurs parce que
devant l'étendue des dégâts
qui d'ailleurs faisait suite à un autre
orage dans l'Allier à Vichy un mois
avant où il y a également eu de beaucoup
de donc dans la région les couvreurs
sont absolument dépassés et donc il y a
encore beaucoup de particuliers ou de
services publics qui qui attendent la
venue des découvreurs il y avait
également un problème
d'approvisionnement tuile au départ donc
malheureusement il est à craindre qu'il
faille encore plusieurs mois pour un
retour à la normale et avec la
multiplication des orages comme par
exemple le week-end dernier la mairie de
Digoin a encore pris l'eau parce que les
bâches ne sont pas ne sont pas la
solution et donc malheureusement cela
dégrade encore les bâtiments donc nous
avec l'ensemble des élus locaux nous
essayons de trouver les tous les moyens
possibles pour convaincre découvre de
venir dans la région pour pour améliorer
cela
merci em sur le boulon sauf si vous avez
une autre question
non dans le processus d'indemnisation
est-ce que c'est assez rapide monsieur
Jeunet finalement puisque on s'aperçoit
que tout ça est aussi très très long et
très long pour être indemnisé d'après
des riverains de votre région alors bien
sûr ça dépend des contrats d'assurance
et des assureurs certains font diligence
très rapidement d'autres se font un peu
tirer l'oreille il y a eu l'attente
également de pour voir passer les
experts pour faire valider les devis
souvent il y a des procédures qui
demandent plusieurs devis et donc comme
je vous ai dit qu'il y a déjà pas
d'entreprises pour pour faire les
travaux obtenir plusieurs devis c'est
compliqué donc sur ces différents points
la collectivité du Grand charolais par
exemple avait mis une cellule d'écoute
des des
usagers en lien avec la sous-préfecture
pour essayer de convaincre les assureurs
effectivement d'accélérer les procédures
et d'être plus souples dans
l'application de celle-ci
merci beaucoup Emmanuel Bouland d'avoir
été avec nous on regarde votre une vous
en parliez charolais un an après la
grêle des toits encore bâchés c'est à la
une du Journal de Saône-et-Loire ce
matin merci Emmanuel d'avoir été avec
nous pour terminer on va parler d'un
sujet que vous suivez évidemment au
Sénat ce sont les agressions les
violences envers les élus locaux Fabien
Genet on en reparle encore de ces
violences malheureusement parce que
lundi tout le conseil municipal de
l'horizon Vaucluse a démissionné après
l'agression d'un adjoint par un habitant
la nouvelle mère de Saint-Brevin a déjà
déposé plusieurs plantes on a
l'impression que malgré les mesures
annoncées par le gouvernement malgré les
lois malgré les plans tout ça se
reproduit comment on arrête ces
violences envers les élus
je crois qu'il faut une prise de
conscience de l'ensemble de la société
vous savez les élus locaux en
particulier les élus municipaux qui
s'engagent dans leur conseil municipal
ou comme mère sont la première ligne la
première ligne finalement de la
République c'est souvent aussi la
dernière ligne parce que lorsque la
brigade de gendarmerie s'est retiré
lorsque la perception a été fermée
lorsque les services publics sont partis
lorsque même parfois la pharmacie ou le
médecin ont quitté le village et bien il
reste les élus locaux et donc ils sont
en première ligne face aux frustrations
de nos concitoyens aux colères à leurs
inquiétudes mais on ne peut pas accepter
de laisser tomber cette première ligne
et donc il faut absolument la soutenir
je crois que le Sénat est très sensible
à ces questions nous avons déjà voté
cette année la loi de Lattre qui permet
la constitution de partie civile pour
les associations d'élus pour accompagner
au mieux ceux qui sont victimes
d'agression
au sein de la majorité sénatorielle nous
considérons qu'il faut aller plus loin
une nouvelle proposition de loi qui est
proposer avec une aggravation des peines
et des sanctions lorsqu'il y a agression
nous souhaitons également que dès le
premier dérapage dès le premier dérapage
il y a une réponse avec par exemple
lorsqu'il y a un jour contre un élu il
puisse y avoir une sanction sous forme
par exemple de travail d'intérêt général
pour que cela ne dérive pas ensuite et
puis il faut accompagner comme je le
disais les élus donc la la protection
fonctionnelle doit être étendue et puis
il faut un meilleur lien avec les
services bien sûr de sécurité de police
de gendarmerie et de justice avec un
avec les procureurs
qui est chargé de ces questions au
gouvernement après l'agression après la
démission l'agression et la démission du
maire de Saint-Brévin ça veut dire que
le plan va dans le bon sens où c'est pas
suffisant la ministre annonce et puis le
Sénat écrit des textes de loi que nous
espérons pouvoir voter très rapidement
pour qu'il puisse recevoir une
application je crois qu'effectivement
dans les différentes sensibilités
politiques il y a une volonté commune de
répondre à cela nous parlions en début
d'interview de la montée de la violence
et du fait qu'il fallait sanctionner
cette montée de la violence je crois
qu'il y a une sorte de continuum et
qu'il faut effectivement que la société
en entier nous nous interrogions sur
cette montée de la violence pour y
mettre un terme
Emmanuel Macron il y a indéniablement
depuis le covid effectivement
cette explosion de la violence et
au-delà des termes je crois qu'il faut
qu'on puisse apporter des réponses alors
ça ça va de l'éducation bien sûr de l'É
des enfants mais également parfois des
adultes et puis une réponse pénale et
vraiment une volonté que nous devons
tous partager de faire société ensemble
et les élus sont là au service de la
population ils doivent également être
respectés vous travaillez au Sénat sur
l'avenir du maire l'avenir de la commune
est-ce que vous êtes inquiets pour
l'avenir du maire est-ce que la
démocratie locale est en danger est-ce
qu'on 2026 on aura suffisamment de
candidats aux élections municipales je
vous parlais de mes visites de terrain
dans mon département c'est vrai que au
gré des contacts que l'on peut avoir on
sent une démotivation d'un certain
nombre d'élus parce qu'il y a bien sûr
cette montée de la violence dans la
société mais il y a aussi une
interrogation très forte sur le sens
même de l'action communale avec la
montée de l'intercommunalité beaucoup de
compétences qui ont été transférées et
puis peut-être même au-delà du transfert
de compétences du fait qu'on donne
beaucoup de choses à faire
l'intercommunalité et donc moins en
commune il y a la loi de neutre avec ses
super intercommunalité une très grande
qui ont éloigné finalement
l'intercommunalité de la mairie et puis
les maires ils se retrouvent à 30 40 50
autour de la table donc vous imaginez
bien je le vois dans ma communauté de
communes lorsqu'on fait un tour de table
à 40 ou 50 on a moins de liberté pour
s'exprimer que lorsqu'on était 7 8 ou 10
et donc les les travaux menés par
Mathieu d'Arnaud sont très attendus je
crois qu'il faut que nous nous
interrogions et que nous puissions
apporter des solutions très novatrices
et je ne doute pas que mon collègue
Mathieu aura la capacité à renverser la
table pour pouvoir défendre cette France
communale qui nous est si cher et on
suivra évidemment les conclusions de ces
travaux merci bien je n'ai d'avoir
invité ce matin dans 20 minutes bonne
journée à vous dans 20 minutes dans le
club des territoires on reparlera du
fond Marianne le rapport du Sénat
conclura que Marlène Schiappa n'a pas
dit la vérité ce sont les mots du
rapporteur Jean-François Husson ont
analysera tout ça dans 20 minutes dans
le club d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est Marine tondeuse
qui nous rejoint